how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have quite a bit of news about the
hawkeye series coming to disney plus
really exciting news and perhaps
specifically some really exciting news
for the agents of shield fans or perhaps
it could be a little bit of
disappointing news and at the same time
it looks like we have
another villain revealed that has a
pretty big connection to hawkeye
and kate bishop in the comics and i'll
break it down in this video
but first big congratulations to brandon
king cantwell for being the winner of
last week's funko pop giveaway
email me in the email in my description
of this video and i'll get you your
prize
and for this week's funko pop giveaway
it's going to be a cyclops funko pop all
you have to do to enter is subscribe to
my channel like this video and leave a
comment down below
so let's start off with the news that
could be very exciting or kind of
disappointing to the agents of shield
fans
in an exclusive report from
fandomwire.com
they have said that marvel studios is
going to bring mockingbird
into the hawkeye series but
unfortunately it will not be the same
mockingbird from agents of shield
in the report from fandomwire they said
we at fandomwire can exclusively reveal
that mockingbird will play a role in the
upcoming disney plus series hawkeye
now before you celebrate adrian pallicki
will not be coming back to play the
character
kevin feige and the company at marvel
studios are looking to recast the role
now what does this mean for the hawkeye
series and agents of shield moving
forward
well unfortunately this pretty much
confirms that we're not really going to
see the agents of shield characters in
the mcu
kevin feige has made it pretty clear
recently that he doesn't consider the
television shows that he had no
oversight over to be a part of the
marvel cinematic universe
and that seems to be true as they are
now reportedly recasting the role
now we hadn't seen mockingbirds since
season 3 of agents of shield
she was supposed to get her own spin-off
series with lance hunter but
unfortunately at abc it fell through
but now she's making her way to the
hawkeye series and will interact with
clint barton and kate
bishop and this will be pretty
interesting to see considering the fact
that in the comics
mockingbird and hawkeye were married
they were married for a bit and would
eventually go on to get a divorce but it
will be interesting to see how this
plays out because hawkeye is already
married in the mcu
and now to talk about the villain news
according to thedirect.com they have
exclusively learned that madame mask
will be appearing in the hawkeye series
and according to the direct marvel
studios right now
is currently in the process of casting
an actress to play the role now this is
another
interesting story arc that i'm excited
to see because she's actually in the
comics an
iron man villain first and foremost
she's even a romantic
interest of tony starks in the comics
now of course unfortunately tony is no
longer with us and it is interesting
that we are getting these iron man
villains
after he's already gone we're getting
the mandarin in sheng chi
and the legend of the ten rings and now
we're getting madame mask
but there are several connections with
madame mask and hawkeye
and kate bishop she's had several
run-ins in the comics with hawkeye and
kate
including an encounter with them in
madrapore and here's where things in the
mcu start to connect between
these new series that are coming out the
magipore setting has been
wildly rumored to appear in the falcon
and the winter soldier so perhaps we're
going to see some sort of a connection
with the two shows and could even see
hawkeye kate bishop and maybe falcon or
the winter soldier together in the
hawkeye series
but madam mask and kate bishop
specifically have also had multiple
run-ins in the comics
and at one point in time it was
discovered that kate bishop's father was
one of the villains clients so there's
going to be a lot of interesting
and connecting story arcs not only with
characters and
shows but between shows as well and
perhaps this is just the way the new
mcu is going to be which is awesome
characters from one show appearing in
other shows and of course kevin feige
has already confirmed that the
characters in these shows
will appear in the movies in the marvel
cinematic universe as well
so exciting things coming up for the mcu
and big news today for the hawkeye
series we have a new villain and
mockingbird although it's not the
mockingbird from agents of shield we're
finally going to see hawkeye and
mockingburn together
so let me know what you think about this
news in the comments down below
and let me know which actress you think
would make a good mockingbird for the
mcu
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you stay up to date on all
of the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and instagram and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof